so the things that i revealed tonight
about hogwarts legacy branching dialogue
options again i said these reminder
things nothing too crazy and then
internally they're referring to three of
the dungeons by the following names the
castle dungeon the cayenne dungeon at
c-a-i-r-n and we we kind of talked about
cairns or typically in fantasy they're
associated with graves and then finally
the goblin dungeon so i don't know if
those names will appear in the final
game i think i don't know it might be
kind of weird if it's like goblin
dungeon the chat got me even more
excited saying what if the goblin
dungeon is in gringotts what an
incredible idea what an incredible idea
then when we started talking about
cayenne's typically being markers for
graves
somebody else said what if it's godric's
hollow and there's a cayenne
a stone monument there
and then we like find a hidden passage
and there's some oh my gosh you guys i i
just get i just get so excited thinking
about it man